everybody hi I'm Rachel Buchholz with
National Geographic Kids magazine
outside Grauman's Chinese Theatre in Los
Angeles California we're talking pandas
kung-fu in the environment and honor the
new movie Kung Fu Panda these kids have
a lot of questions to ask the star at
the new film so we're going to let them
fire away young grasshopper
they call me Jack Black because that's
my name
why do pandas have black spots around
their eyes pandas have black spots
around their eyes because they got
kicked in the face by a mongoose it's
true you know the Great Wall of China
you can see it from space it's so big
how would I get across it that's an easy
one rollerblades you want to see my best
kung fu move go son a little something
like this
if so what can we do to help them
yes pandas are endangered and one thing
you can do to help is to visit them at
the zoo's because what we learned from
captive pandas can help scientists save
them in the wild and don't forget
anything you can do to protect the
planet helps all living things including
pandas and you next question the Summer
Olympics are being held in China this
year if you're participating and what
sport would you win a gold medal all of
them except for synchronized swimming
that's impossible I don't know how they
do it next question is it true that your
friend snakes
yeah I don't like snakes they freak me
out
they give me the shivers if you elected
president what would be the first thing
you would do when you got into office if
I was president okay first thing I would
do is spend half of the federal budget
on combating the climate crisis
I would ensure that our entire country
was as green as possible there'd be
solar panels everywhere a roof of every
house and hood of every car and then I
would do away with school all of it
totally overrated some waste of time
people except for kindergarten because
kindergarten is fun and it actually
means ketchup in Chinese and the fifth
grade fifth grade was fun it was a blast
you know what forget it I'm not doing
away with school bad idea next question
have you ever tried it
Oh bamboo so crunchy good in fact can
someone go and get me a bamboo smoothie
half-caf next question hold one in a
fight Paula King Kong oh that's a tough
one nah Kong is definitely stronger the
post faster and I dare say far more
handsome I'm gonna go with PO next
question remember my little friends it's
the small things that make a big
difference
turn off the lights when you leave a
room use a fan instead of cranking up
the AC and tell your parents buying a
hybrid car will make them cool it won't
really but just tell them that anyway
that's all the time I have little people
remember there's awesomeness inside of
each of you now go do some good with it
where's my bamboo smoothie thanks dad
you put walnuts girl remember you can
use more about Jack Black and confu
and National Geographic Kids magazine
I'm Rachel Buchholz reminding you to
keep on exploring your world okay you
can stop banging the gong now jack